Hi it's me Michelle from Lab Muffin
Beauty science and today I'm going to be
reviewing some products from Krave
Beauty. Krave Beauty is a new brand
launched by Korean skincare YouTuber
Liah Yoo who kindly sent me these
products to review. They don't usually
ship to Australia yet so I'm really
grateful that she sent them to me so
that I could actually get my hands on
them and try them out really early. So
far there are two products available:
Kale-lalu-yAHA and the Matcha Hemp
Hydrating Cleanser. Krave Beauty is built
around the idea of simplicity: that the
basics of skincare should be basic, and
skincare should respect your skin. And
they've definitely delivered with
their first two products. Krave Beauty is also
vegan, cruelty-free, alcohol-free, dye-free,
fragrance-free and essential oil-free.
Firstly: packaging. I personally find
packaging really important and I like
things to look nice on my shelf and
Krave Beauty does look really good.
There's lots of natural colors with the
packaging.
There's even really nice natural colors
with the paper packaging on the outside
as well. I'm almost afraid to throw it
out because it's so pretty.
There's a photo of the star ingredient
on top for both. I really like that it's
got the instructions on the back which i
think is really important because if you
chuck out the paper packaging you're
just left with this. So tells you how to
use it, how often to use it, really nice
coding as well - so it shows you morning
and night - so it's got like a little sun
and a moon... every single day... applying to
wet skin... Unfortunately Krave Beauty only
ships to the US and South Korea for
now, but they do have worldwide shipping
in the works.
Kale-lalu-yAHA. Kale-lalu-yAHA is the first
of the supplement series.
It's got 5.25% glycolic acid at a pH of
3.5 to 4 so it's weaker than most
exfoliants you'll find, but it's not so
low that the glycolic acid is like a
vanity ingredient that does nothing, The
glycolic acid is in a base of soothing
and hydrating aloe water and butylene
glycol. It's also got lots of
antioxidants in it which are great for
potentially reducing free radical damage
So it's got kale, spinach and parsley
extracts. It's also got lots of hydrating
and soothing ingredients which I think
is really really good. So it's got
hyaluronic acid, panthenol, which is also
called vitamin b5, allantoin. Allantoin is
particularly good for calming down
irritation, so if this very gentle
exfoliator does actually cause any
irritation it won't be as much of an
issue, because you've got these anti
irritants in there. This product is
really gentle and I think Kale-lalu-yAHA
is really really good for beginners who
are just starting to use an alpha
hydroxy acid. It's really good for
flattening out texture, dealing with
congestion, clogged pores, and give you
that glowy look. It's recommended that
you use this two to three times a week
but in reality, if your skin is quite
used to alpha hydroxy exfoliants, you can
probably just use it every night. I've
been using it every night. The most
similar product that I have in my stash
to Kale-lalu-yAHA is Pixi Glow Tonic. Pixi
Glow Tonic has 5% glycolic acid at pH 4
to 5, and the lower the pH the more
active the acid is. So Kale-lalu-yAHA is a
little bit stronger than Glow Tonic.
Glow Tonic also has aloe vera as the
base as well, just like Kale-lalu-yAHA. It's
also got a few different extracts like
witch hazel and horse chestnut and
they're both above 5%. And it's also got
a tiny bit of ginseng extract. The big
difference between the two in my
opinion is probably the fact that Pixi
Glow Tonic is fragranced and it's not
a particularly weak fragrance, it's sort
of moderate but it can bother some
people. Kale-lalu-yAHA is actually cheaper than
Glow Tonic - it's $25 for 200 mL versus
$15 for 100 mL. And this is in US
dollars, so this is how much it would be
if you bought it in America. In Australia
Glow Tonic is actually a bit more
expensive, so Kale-lalu-yAHA is an even
better bargain. I personally find that
Glow Tonic is nice but my skin loves
exfoliation, so I prefer a stronger
product. Kale-lalu-yAHA has also got more
humectants, and it's a bit more hydrating
on my dehydration prone skin. And it's
light and gentle enough that I can use
it daily. I've been using Kale-lalu-yAHA on
my face right after cleansing. It's
recommended that you use it on a cotton
pad, so you pour a little bit out and
then swipe it over your face. But wasting
product hurts my soul a little bit, so I
use it without the cotton pad and I just
pour it on my face... pour it on my face. I
pour it on my hand and then I pat it on.
So I guess the palms of my hands are
probably going to be really nice and
glowing soon. I find it really nice to
have Kale-lalu-yAHA as an option in my stash.
There's not that many products like this
on the market. It's perfect for hydrating
skin and giving you gentle low-key
exfoliation without worrying about
stressing out your skin too much,
especially if it's already irritated
from other ingredients like retinol.
Make sure when you're using any alpha
hydroxy acid product you use sunscreen
as well. Alpha hydroxy acids can cause
photosensitivity for a week after you
use it. It doesn't really matter whether
you use alpha hydroxy acids in the
morning or night since the
photosensitivity
increases for so long afterwards anyway,
but I personally prefer using it at
night. If you haven't used an alpha
hydroxy acid product before you might
get a bit of purging, but the soothing
ingredients should reduce the chances of
that. And if you want to find out more
about purging I've got a whole video
about it and how to tell if your skin is
purging or just breaking out.
So overall, Kale-lalu-yAHA: love it. The
Matcha Hemp Hydrating Cleanser. This is
the first of the Core Series and it's a
very gentle cleanser. It's $16 for 120
mL. It contains a whopping 40% matcha.
Now if you look up studies on putting
matcha on your skin you won't actually
find any studies because matcha is not
really the word they use in the
literature. You can find green tea
studies though, so matcha is actually a
form of green tea which has even more
antioxidants than normal. Green tea
contains chemicals called polyphenols
that can act as antioxidants.
Antioxidants are substances that can
soak up damage from free radicals. Free
radicals are really reactive species
that have an unpaired electron. Free
radicals form from all sorts of things:
so environmental stressors like UV light
and pollution, and smoking if you're a
smoker. They can also form from just
normal biological processes. So free
radicals are important chemical
messengers in your body, but if they're
in the wrong place, because they're so
reactive, they can attack other things
inside your body, so things like cell
membranes, lipids, DNA. This free
radical damage which is also sometimes
called oxidative stress can build up and
then it leads to things like skin aging.
The key antioxidant polyphenol in green
tea is called epigallocatechin-3
gallate or EGCG.
It has 25 to 100 times as much
antioxidant ability as things like
vitamin C and E. Green tea also has a
bunch of other polyphenols which are
really antioxidant as well, and these are
going to be really difficult for me to
say: epicatechin, epicatechin-3-gallate and
epigallocatechin. The way Krave Beauty
describes why they put matcha in this
product is that they thought it it'd be
awesome to splash matcha on your face
every day and I totally agree. This
cleanser has a pH of 5 to 6 which is
really good for skin. So cleansers
contain ingredients called surfactants
which is what does the cleansing. The
problem with surfactants is that they
can disturb your skin, so as well as
removing the lipids from your skin which
your skin needs, it can also bind to
proteins in your skin and change their
structure, which makes your skin barrier
more leaky, and this also makes them more
vulnerable to pH changes. High ph
cleansers are really bad for your skin
because they can change your skin pH for
extended amounts of time. The reason this
is bad for skin is that it tends to
interfere with the normal biological
processes in your skin that help it grow
and repair and exfoliate itself. All of
these biological processes tend to be pH
dependent. It's also got other nice
ingredients in it like hemp seed oil,
sweet almond oil and oat extract, which
is really soothing for your skin. Another
ingredient in this cleanser which I
think deserves a bit of cred is methyl
gluceth-10. It's not a really well known
ingredient probably because its name is
so uncatchy
but it's ingredient number 5 and it's
been in a few products that I've been
really liking lately.
Matcha Hemp Cleanser uses gentle
surfactants: so it's got coco-betaine which
is a zwitterionic surfactant, and non-
ionic surfactants like coco-glucoside
and decyl glucoside. It's also got soap
bark extract which contains more non-
ionic surfactants. I'm obsessed with
gentle surfactants in my cleansers
because of my dehydration prone skin. My
skin gets really sensitive when I use
too many harsh surfactants - they make my
skin really tight and itchy and
uncomfortable and it makes it a little
bit bumpy and it makes my pores look
even bigger
so gentle cleansing is probably my
number one skincare need. Another thing I
really like about this cleanser is that
it has a metric buttload of glycerin in
it - it's the third ingredient. Glycerin is
probably my favorite boring skincare
ingredient. It's a cheap humectant which
is really good at attracting and holding
onto water, and it's naturally already in
your skin. Glycerin seems to have more
special properties than fancy humectants
like hyaluronic acid - it can actually get
into the stratum corneum and stay there
for ages, so it's really really good for
dehydrated skin. The cleanser itself is a
clear slightly greenish brown gel and it
lathers up a little bit. It spreads
really really well on your skin so you
actually don't need very much I keep
squeezing a little bit too much and then
I end up washing my face and my neck is
on my chest as well. It smells a little
bit chemically, probably because it's
fragrance free. I really like that this
cleanser gets rid of extra oil on my
skin without stripping it. Afterwards my
skin still feels really plump and soft
and not tight or squeaky which usually
means that my skin is drying out. It's
not amazing at makeup removal but it's
OK at removing light makeup. I've been
using it by itself on days when I stay
at home and don't actually wear much on
my face and I've been using it after
cleansing oil on days when I do wear
lots of makeup. I've been using this
daily in the shower and I even tried it
in the morning over the sink once which
is a pretty big deal for me. I hate
washing my face over the sink my
bathroom set up really badly so every
time I try to wash my face over the sink
I end up bumping my head into the vanity,
I use tons of water to try to get the
cleanser off, it splashes everywhere, it
goes all the way all over the mirror and
there's little water drops on it
afterwards, and then it dries and
you have those little water marks and it
really really annoys me. And then when I
try to wipe off the water marks I leave
lint all over the mirror, and it's just
impossible to get clean. So I hate hate
hate sink washing but I tried it over
the sink. It doesn't work - well it works,
but nothing works for me over the sink
so unfortunately I wish I could
this cleanser convinced me to start
washing my face over the sink, but no, it
seems like nothing is going to ever do
that.
Overall I'm really really impressed with
these products. They're really gentle and
soothing and they slot in so easily
into my routine. I'm not really surprised
by how good they are because Liah's got
similar skin to mine:
she's got oily dehydrated and slightly
sensitive skin as well, plus she's been
reviewing beauty products for ages and
she worked at one of the biggest
manufacturers of beauty products in
Korea so she's had tons of experience
with products, and she knows what works
well for her, and what works well for me
apparently. These are fantastic for
dehydrated skin. I'm really looking
forward to seeing what Krave Beauty
comes out with next. I've seen that
Liah's been talking about sunscreen on
her Instagram and I know she's a big fan
of my favorite filters the Tinosorbs
S and M so I can't wait to see those
products. Thanks so much for watching my
review. If you like my videos you can
subscribe to my channel. If you have any
requests for videos please let me know!
You can also follow me on Instagram and
Facebook and of course I also have tons
of beauty science on my blog. See you
next time for more beauty science talk!